generally we think of Amazon as a
trillion-dollar giant that's mostly
grown due to its dominance in online
retail but in reality nearly half of
Amazon's valuation comes from a startup
that was founded 12 years after Amazon
that is now valued at 500 billion
dollars not only this but this startup
has also been the lifeline of Amazon
making up for their largely unprofitable
retail business so here's the story of
Amazon Web Services
[Music]
people often see amazon.com as a super
greedy retailer that makes a bunch of
money off of essentially slave labor but
really they've been struggling to profit
for basically their entire lifetime even
as recent as 2017 the retail business
lost money as Amazon North America
profited 2.8 billion while international
Amazon lost 3 billion meaning the retail
business lost two hundred million
dollars in total this long-term cache
issue was apparent from the late 1990s
so Amazon started looking into other
businesses to diversify it very early on
after some brainstorming their first
solution to this problem was merchants
calm they realized that their main issue
wasn't pulling in revenue or getting
sales as they were getting plenty of
this but rather fulfilling all their
orders as this left him with no profit
now don't get me wrong here they were
very good at fulfilling orders the issue
was that at their current size they
couldn't offer a competitive price to
physical retailers and profit they
needed to achieve economies of scale to
compete with the big players but doing
so required more profits they were in a
catch-22 situation where they needed to
raise prices to profit and invest the
cheap economies of scale but raising
prices would slow their growth
preventing economies of scale
considering this they decide to simply
maintain their fulfillment business for
now and focus on the online shopping
platform side of the business their plan
was for other businesses to use
merchants calm to build their own online
shopping websites and pay Amazon a fee
for helping them build their site this
way they could continue in the same line
of business but they wouldn't have the
hassle of fulfillment essentially Amazon
was trying to launch Shopify but as a
relatively new company their development
team was very unorganized so instead of
cramming and more work to their existing
employees they decided to start a new
segment to develop this idea andy jazzy
the eventual CEO of AWS says very
quietly around 2000 we became a services
company with really no fanfare
so clearly this project was expected to
be the bigger picture long term business
that possibly even replaced Amazon
calm as it eliminated all the logistics
issues but despite starting a whole new
division to handle this job Amazon still
ran to a bunch of development issues as
projects took much longer than expected
as development continued to lag in 2003
the executives decided to take a step
back and reevaluate their situation they
listed out what they were good at and
what they were not good at which led
them to quickly realize that they were
pretty bad at developing a development
platform but they were great at
fulfilling and shipping orders as well
as running databases to keep track of
all of these activities albeit
unprofitably expanding the online
platform didn't work so they decided to
expand her database skills they didn't
exactly know what to do but they did
shift her focus onto the database I had
their company away from trying to offer
an online shopping website developmental
ironically Shopify would launch the
following year doing just that and would
grow to be valued at over 78 billion
dollars so that definitely was a viable
business model but in the long term AWS
would prove more lucrative anyways
despite the shift in focus it wasn't
until for the discussion that they
realized that most of the Internet
wasn't even built yet it took them
another three years to build up enough
infrastructure but in 2006 their startup
AWS would be the first company to offer
a cloud infrastructure service for the
first several years their services
weren't that sought-after in the market
this isn't to say that Amazon Web
Services wasn't profitable or that it
wasn't growing but it wasn't the full-on
transition into a service segment that
they had hoped for
in retrospect this wasn't because the
market was small but because they were
just so early on to Athene in the
meantime though AWS hadn't blown up
amazon.com was still going rapidly so
they used a profit from AWS
to make up for all the losses from
amazon.com this new revenue stream
enabled Amazon to limit liquidation and
raising more funds to keep em as an
ahkam afloat
I'm sure amazon.com would have survived
either way but AWS gave Amazon the
stability that it needed
allowing them to invest billions into
planes and warehouses and shoo for
ambitious to day and even one-day
delivery times
luckily for Amazon things started to
change in 2013 when Amazon saw an
explosion the Web Services business
which has grown over tenfold from 3.1
billion to 35 billion dollars in revenue
over just six years amazon.com
was also going exponentially during this
time period but as we discussed in the
beginning this increased revenue didn't
make them profitable till 2018
fortunately though AWS was vastly
profitable allowing them to keep up with
the increased losses on the retail side
even after amazon.com became profitable
in North America
AWS profits far outrank amazon.com for
instance in 2018 Amazon's retail site
pulled in a whopping two hundred and
seven billion dollars and net sales but
their operating profit was just five
billion leaving their profit margin at a
measly two point five percent AWS on the
other hand only pulled in twenty five
billion dollars which is obviously a lot
but only about ten percent compared to
the retail income despite this AWS
profited more money at seven point three
billion dollars allowing for a solid
twenty eight percent profit margin or 11
times higher than the retail business
evidently over the past 14 years AWS has
been integral to Amazon as a provider
income which they can then turn around
and invest in amazon.com without AWS
Amazon would have not been able to
invest so much into logistics while
their entire retail site was still
bleeding money and today Amazon would be
nowhere close to the 50 percent market
share they currently own this would also
mean that Jeff Bezos though he'd still
be very wealthy would be nowhere close
to being the richest person on earth and
that's how a small start-up was able to
not only save Amazon but completely
changes trajectory to grow into a
behemoth that it is today did you guys
know that AWS made up 40% of Amazon's
market cap make sure to comment that
down below also if you guys thought this
video explained the role of AWS and
Amazon survival well then make sure drop
a like
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the
next one